the attacks on Kiev have been ramping up
this month but this is a very rare
occasion when it was attacked during the
day as well the whole series of
explosions rocking the center of the
city you can see the puffs of little
smoke up there that's part of the
missile systems being targeted in the
skies mayor Klitschko actually uh posted
a picture of a Russian missile that was
on the streets of the capital leg
doesn't look that so Grand exception you
imagine that was in London it will be a
pretty significant event this is the
16th day that the attacks have been
mounted against the key this month
Ukraine claims has been 35 drone attacks
29 shot down but 40 missile attacks in
the last 24 hours of which 37 they claim
um they've shot down
um but inevitably these are residents
that have been forced to go into this
sort of underground system of keep to
get away from it very reminiscent of
World War II it wasn't just here though
it was also in Odessa the port
facilities at Odessa down near you we're
attacked as well and also unusually
there were five the Ukraine has reported
five aircraft taken out of action at
Kamel nitsky which is just up a way away
from the front line of the fighting
interestingly Belgrade as well up to the
just inside the Russian border the
Russian Governor there said that there
are several settlements that have been
impacted by a lot of shelling this
morning coming from the Ukrainian side
it is worth remembering that the Russian
Logistics military logistics often flows
through Belgrade so it could be to do
with that yeah because right on the
border um what do you know about the
Airfield attack
well it's an odd one this because the
ukrainians rarely comment about Russian
attacks on their military capability but
they did say that five aircraft were
taken out of action they said they were
trying to restore the runway and they're
also trying to put out the the fires
that have been started in they didn't
say whether it's civilian or military if
you look in the region there is a
civilian airport there but it looks
really unlikely that the Russians would
Target a civilian airport whereas there
is a major Ukrainian Air Force military
uh Airfield in that region it's home to
the mig-29s which is the most modern
Ukrainian aircraft plus a few other
Fighters as well now most so it's most
likely that's what their target was
um it's quite difficult it normally
military targets you try and hide them
or you try and move them away you can't
do that with an Airfield it's pretty
fixed and so we've just taken a
satellite picture here of the Airfield
in question and there's several
different ways of storing aircraft one
if you look over your side there's a big
concrete pan there that one you'd expect
to see on on a civilian Airfield or a a
normal training aircraft you can easily
refuel Jets have them all together the
next level of protection though is berms
it's what called berms and you can see
several examples here it's a bit blurry
on there but if we look at here there's
big piles of soil which are try to
protect the aircraft they're generally
taller than the aircraft they don't um
with standard wreck strike but they stop
lots of damage being done and if I step
back here we can look at the hardened
aircraft shelters which are the other
example in fact here there's several of
them here you can barely see them
because they are still reinforced
concrete buildings covered in soil and
then allow grass to grow of them it
allows the aircraft to hide inside and
unless you get a Precision strike with a
specific weapon with the lathe fuse
they're very safe now I reiterate we
don't know exactly what has happened in
Ukraine but it is very rare for them to
report the furrow aircraft are out of
action in that region and therefore be
really interesting to hear more news as
it becomes available and perhaps looking
at the Ukraine's military targets some
might think they'd or they'd be struck a
bit more but but they're not being no
they they they're not at all I mean I
think what's interesting about how this
war is developing is that Russians seem
to have culminated in back Moot and at
the moment
um what you what Russia should be doing
is targeting military targets but
strangely they're targeting uh Kiev
instead now if it's the West we'd be
using satellite technology to find
military targets and then use sensor to
Shooter as quickly as possible to Target
them and it's really odd that Russia's
not doing that it's probably not doing
that because it needs really
professional teamwork to link satellite
headquarters
Etc and they're just not good at doing
actual also it appears that President
Putin who's not a military guy is
directing this war and almost certainly
he's just said bonkiev rather than
actually uh bombing the Russian military
capability regardless I think um it
what's really clear at the moment though
is that the delays in Ukraine mounting
they're offensive for whatever reason
they're delaying actually is providing
Russia with an opportunity to Target
them and cause some significant damage
the ukrainians will be really looking
forward to getting going on their
offensive